if you believe that the radical left
isn't after your children you're
ignoring the fact that they
very very clearly are after your
children so
nickelodeon actually broadcast i'm not
kidding you
a video from a drag queen named nina
west
and forgive my unfamiliarity this is not
a world in which i generally traffic
the drag queen at nina west performed an
original song
about the meaning of the rainbow pride
flag for small children because again
nickelodeon is directed at small
children and is not directed at teens
it is not directed at adults it is
directed at small children
and so we are going to now indoctrinate
children into the
wonders of various sexual orientations
and the complete moral relativity of
human sexuality and we're going to do
this like four and five-year-olds
because confusing children is what
people are in the business of doing
because if you can confuse children and
if you can tell them
that true glory lies in how you identify
on the inside as opposed to you know
complying with basic societal norms not
with regard to even sexuality but with
regard to
just decent human behavior right as in
not sexualizing children
well then that apparently is bad you're
not supposed to do that right we have to
there is no way to discuss gay pride
without coming into conflict
when you're coming to discuss this with
children without coming into conflict
with the reality which is that
it is a sexual orientation which implies
sex which implies you know how to
discuss sex with small children
and they have tv people discussing sex
with small children and gender
orientation with small children
does this sound like a great idea to you
if you're a parent you need to turn off
the damn tv
right the hell now you don't let your
your kids watch
stuff that you haven't pre-screened
because otherwise you end up with this
here is a drag queen lecturing your
child
on a bunch of stuff including by the way
blm there's like a blm fist that appears
halfway through this particular video so
you get a lecture on the gay pride flag
by a man dressed as a woman and
this is going out to four and
five-year-olds this is this is
woke indoctrination of small children on
sexual matters
don't tell me that that isn't abuse of
children it is it is mass abuse of
children
if somebody came into your house and
started doing this to your child without
your consent
you would immediately call the cops okay
i'm not talking about like physically
abusing a child i'm talking about if an
adult came into your house a man dressed
as a woman came into your house and
started singing to your child about the
wonders of various sexual orientations
and your kids five you would call the
cops
okay well you turned on the tv so the
idea is that the consent is yours
that you have now consented but how many
parents have actually consented seeing
how many parents knew this was going to
appear on nick really how many parents
were sitting around going i'll bet that
what they're going to broadcast today is
a a
radical gay propaganda video directed to
children
by the way you can be an advocate of gay
rights and still believe this is not
appropriate for children
because it's not appropriate for
children and here's some rather
inappropriate material for children
appearing on nickelodeon
doesn't it just fill you with pride
showing who you are on the inside
with the pride flag up high
[Music]
fills you with pride showing who you are
on the inside so notice also
that there has been a different sort of
approach
to why kids are supposed to be told
about this stuff so it used to be the
kids need to be told about this stuff
because if you are five or six years old
there may be a kid in your class who has
two mommies or two daddies
right that was the original thing right
this was the the what was it
uh has two mommies heather has two
mommies right the heather has two
mommy's book was a controversy maybe 15
years ago
the idea was you need to teach kids
because there might be a kid in the
class who doesn't have a mom and a dad
but actually has two dads or two moms
okay now that was foolish because why
would you have to teach every kid in
america about this
as opposed to just dealing with it when
your kid comes home and asks about it as
a job for parents but
put that aside this is no longer
directed at the kids parents
now this is directed at children
themselves
you a five year six-year-old you might
identify as a trans kid
you might identify as a drag queen
okay that is it's an attempt to
indoctrinate confusion into children
that's all it is
we'll get some more on this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that you're about to have an amazing
summer because things are opening back
up
but as you are out and about you need a
fantastic pair of wireless earbuds
you know what i'm about to say the only
pair of earbuds that you should be
wearing are raycons
raycon is disrupting the electronics
industry by making great sound
available for everyone their wireless
earbuds start at half the price
of other premium audio brands raycon
earbuds will give you six hours of
playtime seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass a more compact design for a
comfortable noise isolating fit
raycon offers their wireless earbuds in
a range of fun colors and patterns
with a variety of fit options no
dangling wires no stems one of the best
things about raycons you can customize
them to fit your ear
perfectly which is exactly what i do the
company was co-founded by ray j
celebrities like snoop dogg and brandy
are obsessed with raycons and so am i so
a lot of people from a lot of different
backgrounds love their raycons
raycon has a 45 day free return policy
here's what you've
got to do click the link in the
description box or go to buyrecon.com
shapiro yt you get 15 percent off your
recon purchase today
nina west apparently had himself i i i
don't know that nina west identifies as
a woman
or is a drag queen who identifies as a
man there there are both
okay so nina west didn't just do a song
for
nickelodeon writ large nina west also
did a song for blues clues blues clues
is directed at three-year-olds
i have small children blues clue is
directed at three
four five-year-old children these are
small kids there are no 11 year olds
watching blues clues
and now you have blues clues having its
own pride parade featuring a drag queen
for small children don't tell me this
isn't about indoctrination of kids it's
100 about indoctrination of kids
and and by the way if you think the
people who are doing this don't know
what they're doing you're an idiot of
course they know what they're doing
their idea is that they have to counter
you the parent you the evil parent
the evil traditionalist parent who
teaches your kids that there's a
difference between men and women and
that men and women get married and then
have babies
you have to be countered right now
because you might be indoctrinating
a pseudo a little fascist like yourself
and so we have to get a hold of your kid
and remold your kid
there's no other explanation for why
this stuff is being broadcast on
children's television
and you know this really comes down to
you the parent turn off than amtv here's
what appeared on blue's clues
it's time for a pride parade families
marching one by one hurrah
hurrah this family has two mummies they
love each other so proudly and they all
go
marching in the big parade
this family has two daddies they love
each other so proudly these babas are
non-binary they love each other so
proudly
trans members of this family all love
each other so proudly and they all go
marching in the big parade
come join the fun you see how it morphed
right so it started off even this video
started off with there are some kids who
have two mommies or daddies and then it
moves into
some are non-binary okay now you have to
explain to children that they could have
a malleable gender which is number one a
lie
and number two is super confusing to
tiny kids
to smoke also you have to you have to
say to a small child
who thinks he's a robot today that he
might actually be a girl
okay the only reason nickelodeon is
doing this is to please
its most fervent radical supporters and
again these people think they are doing
good understand
that this is not people who are just
making a market decision because the
market for this stuff is rather small
it is people who believe they are doing
a social good by indoctrinating your
kids in a particular
style of thinking they're taking your
kids away from you
and if given power these folks will do
the exact same thing physically they
will take your kids away from you
okay i this sounds like chicken little
sky is following stuff
but it has already happening so long as
your kid is quote unquote diagnosed with
something
okay there if you the eventuality here
is pretty obvious
you're gonna send your four or
five-year-old kids to school your four
or five-year-old kid is going to say a
dumb confused things because kids who
are four
or five are dumb and confused i know i
have small kids
your four or five-year-old will go to
school they'll say something like
i want to wear a dress today a little
boy and instead of being at home where
you would say no that's silly
let's put on some pants instead of doing
that the teacher's gonna
you should you should see how you feel
in a dress it will be encouraged
and then if you object as a parent they
will say that you are
you are stifling your child's growth
because what we have here is two
conflicting visions of how kids are
civilized
one suggests that kids must be civilized
to a quote unquote
non-judgmental society in which all
behavior is treated equivalently
except for religious and traditionalist
behavior which is treated with scorn
and that kids should be encouraged
to to experiment with gender and
experiment with sexual orientation and
experiment with everything and another
view
that says that things like biological
sex exist that male and female exist
that there are in fact moral preferences
with regard to sexual behavior
and those of us who are libertarian on
the right when it comes to government
our say we say listen you're an adult
you get to do what you want but get what
you don't get to do is indoctrinate kids
and those on the left they say you on
the right don't get to do what you want
and we're gonna
and we're going to indoctrinate your
kids that's what this conflict is going
to come down to
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment